If you're afraid to have a baby,
watch this video.
We just got in and out wearing cute little outfits.
She just. Can we please get more content like this?
There's so much negativity out there about motherhood and about babies
and about children,
and, like,
we all get it.
All moms get it.
We know how hard it is.
We know it's difficult,
but it's also so much freaking fun.
Like, it's so fun
to hang out with these little people that run around your house
and to do things with them.
It is the best.
And I often speak to moms
who are struggling with postpartum depression,
and I work with them,
and one of the biggest things that help is seeing moms like this one
who let themselves enjoy being a mom
and seeing women who shed light on the positives of being a mom
and how amazing it is
and how parenthood is literally the best thing they've ever done.
Women know how difficult it is to be a mom,
but being able to be reminded of how amazing it is and how fun it is
is so important.
I love content like this.